Now the answer is that it actually does do something.
It produces an output.
If it takes numbers as inputs then it produces their sum.
But it works also if we pass in strings.
It would produce the concatenation of the 2 strings,
because the "+" operator
works on both strings and numbers.
Given the name sum, it makes more sense to use it to add numbers,
but it will work perfectly well using strings as well.
And let me just show you that in the Python interpreter.
So now, I changed sum to return the value of a.
I have 2 variables that are strings.
We've introduced s to 'Hello ' with a space at the end and t to 'Dave!'
Now I'm calling sum, passing in s and t,
and what I get as a result is Hello Dave!
Note that it does not change the value of s.
s is passed into the first input.
Even though we change the value of a here,
that does not change the value of s.